welcome back so we've been exploring the
extremum seeking control algorithm which
essentially is a smart version of
perturb and observe where you jiggle
your control input you measure some kind
of corresponding jiggle in an objective
function some high-level objective you
want to maximize and you steer your best
estimate for what the control value
should be based on that information that
you get from this the sinusoidal
perturbation okay so here we have a cost
function that's quadratic if I'm to the
left of the optimizing value in this
case U equals 5 when I jiggle it tells
me I should increase u if I was above
then it would tell me I should decrease
U and essentially you can track this
this optimum value of your objective
function J pretty pretty easily just by
adding the sinusoidal perturbation now
extreme seeking control is particularly
interesting when your system has
dynamics when it's not just the static
quadratic cost function but there's some
dynamical system that gives rise to this
objective like a fluid or some power
electronics or something like that where
there's actually dynamics and what's
also interesting is when there are
disturbances or parameter shear systems
that are changing over time that you
can't measure okay so what would be more
interesting in this case is if this
objective function was actually moving
around based on some unknown parameter
that's hard to measure so what I'm going
to tell you about now I'm just going to
go through a few examples of how myself
and my collaborators have used extreme
seeking control in the past to control
actual real-world systems so we're going
to start working through the
practicalities of this ok so one of the
first systems I applied extreme seeking
control to was solar array optimization
so this is a solar array actually a pair
of solar arrays that we had outside of
our lab in Princeton when I was a grad
student you can read all of the details
in this paper down here but the basic
idea is that when you're operating a
solar panel array an array of solar
panels you have to change the Opera
reading conditions you have to change
kind of the the set current or the set
voltage depending on the time of day or
the cloud cover basically the amount of
solar irradiation that hits these panels
will change the optimal set point where
you should be maintaining your your
power inverter so these are tied into
the power grid using what's known as a
grid tied inverter it basically takes
this DC power chops it up a bunch and
reforms it into these sine waves that it
then feeds in as AC current into the
into the power grid I'm oversimplifying
a bit I'm not a power electronics guy
but that's basically what's happening
these output you know DC and a power
inverter chops them up and reforms them
into AC current which it feeds into the
grid the process of chopping it up and
feeding it into the grid actually
creates a sinusoidal perturbation which
we can then use for extreme seeking
control so that was that was what we did
here so you can model your array using
this basic this basic diagram here
there's some capacitance and inductance
and so on and so forth and what you're
really trying to do so these are the
power versus voltage and power versus
current curves so you want to maximize
the power that's what you're feeding
into the into the grid you want to
maximize the power by setting V or I to
be at this peak that's optimizing value
okay and this is as the irradiance as
the amount of sunlight changes okay so
the lowest curves here are for low solar
irradiance and the highest curves here
are for very high solar irradiance and
in the middle of Princeton New Jersey
you know you have clouds coming over in
the day you have this massively varying
solar irradiance even over the course of
minutes or seconds let alone hours okay
and so the idea is that you're going to
have to move this is normalized so
you're gonna have to change your set
voltage or current throughout the day to
maintain this peak power or else you're
gonna have suboptimal performance okay
now again
this grid-tie inverter that we were
using at the time by nature of the fact
that it's chopping this up into this you
know 60 Hertz AC sine wave means that
means that we get this natural
sinusoidal ripple on top of our control
signal and we can measure did our power
go up or down based on those swings in
the rippling input signal and so we use
that to design an extremely seeking
controller to maintain peak performance
in this array and what you can see here
these are actually the the solar
irradiance basically how much sunlight
is hitting those panels on two
consecutive days in New Jersey so on I
don't know which one's day one and day
two but at one of the days you see that
it's a pretty nice curve over the course
of the day so basically the Sun comes up
it gets brighter and brighter and
brighter and brighter until peak and
then it gets dimmer and dimmer and
dimmer and dimmer okay that's this first
curve here and even in that case we
still have to adjust our either our
current or our voltage continuously over
the course of the day to track the
optimizing power condition but then on
day two you can see this is an example
of kind of real New Jersey weather so in
day - there's cloud cover the cloud
cover breaks sporadically and you get
lots of sunlight then the clouds roll
over you get lots less sunlight and this
is very highly variable over the course
of you know minutes or seconds so I'm
zooming into this little box here on day
two and you can see kind of the power
output is wildly swinging over the
course of you know just a matter of
minutes or hours and this is the
optimizing current the control current
that we have to continuously adjust to
maintain the maximum the maximum power
condition okay so what we're doing here
you can't really see it because this is
so fast at 60 Hertz but there's this
incredibly fast sinusoidal ripple on top
of this current and we're using that
signal to measure did the power go up or
down and what we're doing is essentially
adjusting this
so when there is the opportunity to gain
more power we modify the the set current
and we maintain the maximum possible
power and I don't know if you can see
here but actually there is the
theoretical maximum power which is this
blue line and then there's our extreme
seeking controller on top of that and so
basically it's almost perfect ability to
track this maximum allowable power by
jiggling this this current in real time
ok so you can apply this to solar array
optimization that was kind of my first
experience using extreme seeking control
since then we've applied it to lots of
other systems so one system that I think
is really interesting is self-tuning
fiber lasers so this is work with shing
phu and nathan cuts at u-dub so the idea
here is that i have some kind of a fiber
laser this is like a fiber optic laser
and what you want to do is you want to
get the maximum energy pulses out of
this laser possible and you have some
optical components that you can tune so
there are these for you know essentially
optical components wave plates and
polarisers that you get to turn to
filter out different aspects of this
this laser pulse to allow it to to
synchronize into this mode locked
high-energy pulses okay this is kind of
old technology in in laser physics but
what is really interesting is if you
have one of these lasers in your lab you
go into the lab in the morning you turn
this laser on and it's not mode locked
it doesn't have these high energy single
pulse outputs that you want and so what
you have to do is you have to tune these
these these wave plates and polarisers
and an expert can do this pretty quickly
you basically tune these until the
system becomes mode locked and has these
high energy peak pulses that you want
now what confounds the issue is that
this this fiber has an unknown and very
difficult to measure a quantity called
the birefringence if I twist the fiber
the birefringence changes if I heat up
the
the birefringence changes and this has a
huge impact on the mode locking and the
output of this laser so over the course
of the day the room gets five degrees
warmer this birefringence changes and I
need to continuously modify or you know
maybe at discrete instances that
throughout the day I'll need to retune
the system to keep it mode locked okay
even worse let's say someone bumps into
the laser table and it knocks this fiber
into a new birefringence value I have to
start all over again and reach in the
system so we thought this was a perfect
example to apply extreme seeking control
and so what we were trying to do what
you see here are essentially the wave
shapes these are the the shapes of the
actual pulses for different conditions
of these wave plates and polarisers what
we want was this this solid peak here
kind of a narrow high-energy pulse that
corresponds to this diamond this diamond
here okay now
the dashed line here is the raw energy
output of this laser and so what you can
see is that as I if I just did extreme
so you can control purely based on the
energy what would happen is I would walk
up this curve until this point here but
this gray region is where my mode
locking fails so something really
important I think everybody who does
optimization should know is that very
often and often I can optimize myself
off of a cliff even though I get more
energy it's this chaotic solution here
where basically it's more energy but
it's not a coherent wave pulse so I
don't want to just maximize energy
instead what I do is I divide by the
kurtosis of the signal this this higher
moment here to penalize just energy and
to instead favor energetic solutions
that are also narrow okay there are
these narrow pulses so basically what
I'm telling you is in this mode locked
laser case we had to use expert
knowledge to design an objective
function that gave us the pulses that we
wanted we thought maybe just maximizing
energy would work
we found that we would optimize
ourselves right off a cliff into this
chaotic non mode lock solution so we had
to design an objective function in this
solid curve here that promoted pulses of
the shape that we actually wanted and
then what we did was we put a little
sinusoidal perturbation onto all of
these wave plates and polarisers and we
allowed those those jiggling
measurements we could measure the output
and we applied the extrema so you can
control a lot to essentially bring the
system into mode locking and keep it
there
even when the birefringence changed in
time and so that's what this looks like
here you essentially can measure your
objective function you feed that
objective function back into our extreme
seeking controller which has the
sinusoidal perturbation and then you
apply those kind of jiggling signals to
some servo motors that actually move
these wave plates and polarisers and so
what I'm showing you here is actually
just modifying this polarizer angle you
could do this you could jiggle all of
these servos but now we're only kind of
jiggling this this polarizer and what
you can see is that very rapidly it
finds a good set value that increases
the energy increases the objective
function and increases the power output
for each of these these pulses okay so
it's kind of what we want we want these
pulses to be narrow and high-power we
have we obtain that it's measurable by
our objective function which increases
and we also increase the energy per
pulse just by applying this equation
free extreme secant controller this is
particularly nice because modeling this
this laser is pretty challenging and
measuring and modeling the birefringence
might be impossible so there's this
unknown disturbance that I don't want to
measure all I want to do is compensate
for it so I jiggle this extreme of
seeking control signal and even if this
birefringence is changing in time I can
track those optimal settings that give
me high energy mode lock solutions okay
another example we've applied this to
this was an experiment run by Barrett
Nowak in poitiers France and Vladimir
Paris on ovitch and collaborators
designed the control laws and ran all of
the experiments of this and essentially
what we did was we applied extreme
seeking control to try to increase or
decrease the mixing in a fluid mixing
layer so what we had here there's the
splitter plate and above the splitter
plate there is high speed flow and below
the splitter plate there's low speed
flow and what you get are these
kelvin-helmholtz instability and vortex
roll-up which eventually break down at
this downstream location where we can
measure measure the flow and what we're
trying to do there are these little
pressure ports that you can blow air on
the side of the splitter plate we're
trying to design a strategy for blowing
out of those little those ports to
either increase or decrease mixing
downstream very hard nonlinear control
problem you definitely don't want to try
to model this system so equation free
methods are ideal and we applied extreme
seeking control to get either better or
you know increased or decreased mixing
in this now in this example we found it
interesting because the flow is so
nonlinear there's actually lots of local
optimum solutions
local optimum strategies based on the
parameterization of the control law and
so extremes you can control was only
able to find a local optimizer and not
the global optimal solution okay so
that's a caveat right if you have a
really complicated cost landscape you
have to be careful that you're not just
finding a local optimizer ok the last
example I want to show you is work that
we did with Michaela Johnson and Nathan
Koontz from chi Mehta where we
essentially optimize the performance of
a metamaterial antenna array to get
better beam steering with less
side lobes so I'll tell you what this
means in a minute okay so here's our
schematic basically this metamaterial
antenna can sit on top of the roof of a
car and talk to satellites ok and the
satellite is pointing in this main
direction so you want to focus all of
your energy into maintaining an antenna
beam in that direction
but based on the nonlinear physics of
this this meta material you essentially
get these side directions energy and
side directions which are
not helpful so first of all they waste
your power and energy energy but also
there's rules from the FCC about how
much you can pollute sidebands so if I'm
trying to listen to my my satellite but
I'm essentially polluting the airwaves
with all of these side frequencies then
I can get shut down so there's this this
need to track this main beam and bring
down these side lobes to be compliant
and so what this looks like essentially
is you have some control pattern that
you you establish on this metamaterial
antenna and it gives a beam pattern here
so this is the main beam pointing to the
satellite but this is some kind of a
side lobe interference that I want to
bring down as much as possible okay so
that's this picture here with the car I
have a lot of energy in the main beam
but I also have a lot of energy in these
side lobes and so essentially what we do
is we add another kind of corrective
control pattern with some some you know
frequency and amplitude and the idea is
what we want to do is we want to add on
something that a negative side lobe to
cancel out the side lobe and give us
this purple curve down in the bottom
okay and what we're trying to do is
we're trying to sweep through these
parameter spaces to find the right
control pattern that brings the side
lobe down as much as possible and that's
what Michaela was able to do with the
extreme of seeking control was
essentially to reduce the side lobe
significantly by optimizing these
parameters to find the best side lobe
cancellation okay so this is another
example where the electronics themselves
are pretty fast compared to these
perturbations and you're able to
actually bring down the side lobe using
this extreme seeking optimization okay
so in all of these cases you're
essentially able to account for unknown
disturbances in the case of the
metamaterial antenna array we simulated
warming so we we the physics changes
when it gets hotter or colder and so
what we did was we simulated antenna
warming over the course of a day and we
use the extremist ikan controller to
essentially
tract that that optimal objective value
in yellow here and if we didn't have our
extremists seeking controller as the
antenna warmed up we would actually lose
performance over what is what is
possible okay
so in all of these cases what we did was
we used extreme seeking control on a
system where the internal dynamics
equilibrated relatively quickly compared
to the perturbation and we use that
perturbation to optimize our control
strategy for some high-level objective
in the case of the the solar array we
wanted to maximize the array performance
in the case of the fluid we wanted to
increase or decrease mixing for the
laser we wanted these high-energy narrow
pulses and in the metamaterial we wanted
to decrease our side lobe as much as
possible and in all of those cases with
this perturbative signal even without
having any equations or dynamics without
knowing any of the equations for the
dynamic we were able to obtain
performance increases just based on this
kind of extreme seeking control
perturbative strategy okay there are
tons more applications I'm just showing
you what we've done kind of with myself
and collaborators on a few systems
people have applied this to combustion
problems to make combustors quieter to
optimize formation flight you name it
people have applied extreme seeking
control optimization so it's a go-to
method you should definitely try it out
on your own systems but beware
it can give you local optimum optimum
solutions so you have to have a good
initial initial guess to get more
globally optimal solutions okay thank
you